[Musique]
c'est parti
5 heures du matin report taille des
anglais 27 km et surtout un magnifique
territoire à découvrir le chemin des
anglais direction sani c'est parti
[Musique]
très bien faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour eux
mais très chaud aussi c'est là qu'on se
dit que cette saint cloud ouais merci
pour l'encouragement au bas je suis tout
le monde je me sens bien c'est le plus
important c'est n'a rien à voir que son
titanic afssa non non tu assez
différente c'est le même bien j'aime
bien la chaleur dollars
[Musique]
qu'at-elle à manille
regardez comme il est beau c'est omar à
la
[Musique]
enfin la cote alors lorsque le soleil se
lève sur le chemin des anglais
on va après une demi-heure de course ces
gars-là c'est ça ouais ouais c'est un
magnifique chemin avec des dalles
désorganisés mais tour s'étaient
organisés en tout cas au site historique
du conservatoire du littoral mais
surtout entre dieux du au quotidien par
les agents du département
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite
premier ravine parce que gaga connaît
comment s'appelle cette ravine personnes
connues ou non la ravine des bons
coureurs c'est ravine à malheur
entretien le sentier vraiment si la
pluie tombe c'est des mois des moines ni
puni vraiment aux sessions rôle jaloux
pour ironiser le second siècle la
qualité du travail
magrez difficile mais les bienfaits d'un
an et demi
il ya une dimension historique très
forte mais qui a aussi une dimension
liée au patrimoine naturel
nous sommes sur un site où avant
l'arrivée de l'homme il y avait une
belle forêt sèche
aujourd'hui à l'échelle de la réunion il
reste 1 % environ de forêt dite sèche
un des objectifs de la collectivité sur
ce massif de la grande chaloupe
c'est de contribuer à la reconstitution
de cette forêt sèche
m
une heure et demi de course
bon nous on arrivait à grande chaloupe
mais les premiers sont très loin
incidente retenu par le département
surtout à travers le lazaret au musée
historique ainsi plein d'histoires qu'on
va découvrir tout de suite pour partie
[Musique]
je les invite à venir découvrir le
lazaret de la grande chaloupe parce que
on a tous en tant que réunionnais au
moins 1 ans est engagé qui est passé par
ce lieu de quarantaine c'était vraiment
le départ du métissage réunionnais
puisque dans les indiens ont rencontré
les africains qui ont rencontré les
chinois etc
donc c'est le lazaret de la grande
chaloupe en fait ils représentent le
berceau du métissage culturel
réunionnais ah oui attaque la côte est
que le sourire
déjà c'est bien ça parce que c'est ma
première course ok vous pratiquez la
presse qu'on traite le curé dilatoire
guy roux a pas d'heure quand on se sent
libre pendant le grand raid là quel goût
il a sorti à ce moment là est différent
plis et qui est plus difficile à way you
lie le prix fort parfois coûteux
d'accord à 10h30 la partie
oh
ah ah
un petit coup de pavés ça faisait
longtemps
daniela fan club
c'est beau rien rien paulissen
combien de kilos matelas 7 km on arrive
au colorado
on voit la boule qui est juste là mais
quand même cette terre où jal fait mal
le silence de l'effort au long sa
machine design est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est nous
oui
pour
[Applaudissements]
comment tu finis là c'est bien l'asie
oh
ah ah
cette deuxième édition de terre de
treuils vient de sortir aux
je
[Musique]